I am also witnessing many many of my
friends leaving I just drove back from
the airport early this morning earlier
this morning there about five or six
moving trucks and I'm kind of counting
them now because I had a friend come
over last night tell me he's moving to
Florida and these are basically upper
middle class and wealthy people there
the tax base to the city and I've never
wondered about you know since maybe I
stopped being a liberal hey I always ask
them why do you attack rich people so
much don't you realize you need them to
pay for the poor people let's move
forward to sort of what's going on today
because there's a lot of stuff happening
in our cities I know you're no fan of
your current mayor even though you still
live in New York City but de Blasio
seemingly has done a series of things
that the earth that are the exact things
that you were trying to clean up when
you became mayor so can you can you talk
a little bit about what it's like to
live in a city that you love that you
were the mayor of to watch it go
backwards and as you know I've mentioned
this the other day but I had I've at
times in in my family's history we had
dozens I think at one time something
around 50 family members at one time
that lived in New York City
we now have one person left my sister
and her husband and two kids just left
over the last two months I now have one
second cousin left that's it after
having a rich history in New York City
it kills me to say that but can you talk
about what's going on in New York City
right now and and maybe what you would
do to turn around some of this stuff
well first of all it's the status I've
ever been about New York City I'm much
more down about it than I was let's say
when I ran or even when I was US
Attorney I mean when I was the US
attorney I wasn't sure I wanted to run
for mayor but I was seeing all the
things that were wrong with New York
City that's when the 2000 murders a year
were taking place then the Mafia had
control of had almost every business
in this video I mean you couldn't build
a building you couldn't have your
garbage taken out without paying but I
always felt there was solutions to this
there were things that we could do and I
always felt there was the will there to
change it now I'm not maybe it's because
I'm not as involved in politics and I
don't go to the local groups as much I
don't feel that same desire to change
it's almost the hopelessness and I am
also witnessing many many of my friends
leaving I just drove back from the
airport early this morning earlier this
morning there about five or six moving
trucks and I'm kind of counting them now
because I had a friend come over last
night tell me he's moving to Florida and
these are basically upper middle class
and wealthy people there the tax base to
the city and I've never wondered about
you know since maybe I stopped being a
liberal I I always ask them why do you
attack rich people so much don't you
realize you need them to pay for the
poor people and when I was the mayor of
the city my budget but budgets videos
you know larger than all but about ten
state I need a tremendous amount of
money to take care of Medicare Medicaid
of welfare aid for children aid for
battered children all the things we do
the public hospital system New York City
provides universal health care through
its public hospital system only place in
America I think that does denon we've
been doing it for hundred and twenty
years though our bills are very high so
who pays those bills Wall Street all
those beautiful apartments you see on
Park Avenue and and Fifth Avenue and
that on the west side now and every time
a new area gentrified and the tax base
started to go up I would see it as I can
do more for people I can do I can I can
do more to make this city
a little more balanced in terms of rich
and poor and a little more opportunity
for people to move out of poverty
because for me there's no question that
capitalism is the only way out of
poverty the rest of it is a is a false
program that's presented to people by
con so what would you do when you know
like little things like that you can now
jump a turnstile at the subway and you
know they won't find you they won't stop
you and then now we see I mean there's
videos every day on Twitter you see 20
people do it at once kids just open up
the door you know that the handicap
accessible door and just let tons of
people in that that in many ways de
Blasio's plans which sort of sound right
or we want to help people that are poor
that's that's always how it's sold
actually encourage lawlessness and then
and then really let's talk about just
the the rioting that's happening all
over the city I've got a friend I've got
a friend who lives on Spring Street who
has abandoned New York City he's got a
great apartment he hasn't been there in
months and his friend took a video from
his apartment and and all hell was
breaking loose I mean it truly look like
a third world in New York City you know
when I was a prosecutor for many many
years 16 17 18 years I was a federal
prosecutor which meant I always tried
very big case by cases you don't try the
small cases as it local prosecutor
you'll try the murder case and the the
theft case federal prosecutor you're
trying organized crime you're trying
very very intricate financial fraud high
enough level so it arises to federal
time I probably I was not a natural
proponent of the broken windows theory
didn't even make sense to me when it was
first told to me because I always
thought we paid too much attention to
the small things not enough attention is
a big crime and it was taught to me by
about 1981 when I was the associate
attorney general the United States we
established a commission on violent
crime and professor James Q Wilson was
the vice chair of it and I got very
close to Professor Wilson who developed
this theory at Harvard with with
Professor Kevin
and this what he tried to explain to me
was first of all you're not an expert on
street crime I'm gonna make you one
you're an expert on bi-level climb even
mafia crime is high-level crime but look
let's take a look at street crime that's
what you did for to you he said it awful
lot of awful lot of it has to do with
what the young people see in the
community and let's make it he said
let's make it really simple if they see
a lawful community where the expectation
is that you don't ruin other people's
property by putting a graffiti all over
that you have to pay when you go through
the turn stop if you take something from
someone you have to give it back well
there are punishments for that he said
if a society is based on that you have
very little big brunt reverse it if the
society looks like your New York where
everything is filled with rafidhi as if
somebody's property doesn't mean
anything where you don't have to pay for
the turn-turn stuff where you can spit
on the sidewalk where you can urinate in
the street where you can do anything you
want the attitude begins at a very early
age that there there are no limits there
are no restriction and by the time you
start to get to the big crime it's
really too hard to deal with so I even
translated that into my theory of how
you stop a riot which they failed to do
this time and we never failed to do it
you stopped a riot
before it isn't right you anticipate you
see a protest wonderful things protest
people have a right to call me names
call you names whatever they want to do
but I used to he used to give him a
lecture because I had to Jenkins had so
many protests I just had to stop it cold
I wasn't gonna have any though I gave a
speech and I said let's understand each
other you can have all the protests you
want I'm Pro First Amendment you can do
anything you want protested
however the minute you throw around you
Jim you're not gonna get arrested you
gotta go to Rikers Island I'll let you
sit there for a day before I even take
you for a judge if you scratch a car
you're gonna get arrested if you burn
anything I'm gonna try to put you in
jail for a long time and if you
physically harm someone we're talking
five six seven eight years and if you're
a juvenile I won't treat you as a
juvenile two years an adult so I'm gonna
be really really nice to you if you have
a peaceful protest I'm gonna protect you
I'm gonna make it easy for you to do it
and I don't really care what you say you
can call me a Nazi you can call me
whatever you want but it isn't gonna be
the last act of criminality it's the
first one we're going to go after
because David Dinkins had a theory he
called venting and it caused the Crown
Heights and the Washington Heights riots
they let it go on for three days and by
the time Ray Kelly had to solve it in
Crown Heights many many Jewish people
have been one had been killed many have
been beaten was kind of a pogrom the
same thing in Washington Heights and
that's essentially what happened to us
you know in all those democratic cities
in Minnesota they didn't enforce the law
for three or four days in New York I
mean I have pictures of people going
into stores walking out with television
walking out with liquor and the cops are
watching cops are not observers of crime
but not there to record the crime been
there to stop it if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell